and the Fort Worth star-telegram reports
the flight attendants union chief is
asking people to please with whole your
judgment on American Airlines attendant
passengers say he hit a mother of twins
with a stroller during a brought
boarding process video showed him later
challenged another passenger to a fight
American Airlines has apologized to the
mom CBS News spoke to a woman who is
right there and watched it all go down
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport outside Washington with what she
saw Kris good morning well good morning
it appears according to American
Airlines that this all started as a
passenger was boarding a fly from San
Francisco to Dallas and was trying to
carry a stroller onto the airplane that
was just too big to go in the cabin now
the airline is getting pretty high marks
for how it's responded to the PR crisis
grounding that flight attendant in
swiftly apologizing but this comes at a
time when the industry is under a
microscope for how it treats customers
the video does not show the mother being
hit by the stroller or what led up to
the incident as the camera rolled she is
crying and distraught
passenger Olivia Morgan says she saw the
male flight attendant wrestling the
stroller away from the woman away from
her and it almost gets the little baby's
head I said to him something like what
are you doing I'm gonna hit that baby in
the head and then he was yelling at me
to stay out of it the passenger in the
first-class cabin then confronted the
crew member with the captain holding him
back the unnamed flight attendant dares
the passenger to throw a punch
American Airlines opened an
investigation saying the actions of our
team member captured here do not appear
to reflect patience or empathy we are
disappointed by these actions the flight
attendants union said neither the
company nor the public should rush to
judgment he snapped when he shouldn't
have airline industry analyst Henry Hart
a veldt says flight crews work under
enormous pressure airlines are staffing
their planes with the minimum number of
required flight attendants and that's
not right for the passenger or for the
employee either
the mother was later placed on a
different flight and given $1,000 flight
voucher earlier this month a United
Airlines passenger was dragged off a
plane in Chicago United was criticized
for its response initially blaming the
passenger for refusing to give up his
seat and waiting days to apologize
in contrast American has apologized
directly to the family upgraded them all
on their flights home to Argentina to
first-class and issued a full refund the
flight attendants union is criticizing
that first-class passenger who stood up
saying it can be a violation of federal
law to threaten a flight crew member an
American is acknowledging it simply
can't have employees trying to pick
fights with fliers on its airplanes
Norah alright Chris thank you so much